[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
et
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
les mecs
alors c'est beaucoup mieux dans le style
match parce qu'on n'était pas aux
conques la musique partait au moment où
on est là reste vous voulez refaire
oui on est jeune ou golden buzzer non
mais par contre alors juste je tiens à
m'excuser auprès de tout le monde et des
téléspectateurs en fait on se rappelle
plus de toute la chorégraphie que ça
fait un peu plus d'un an qu'on a tourné
la séquence à d'accord après le 2 août
je voudrais dire aux téléspectateurs je
les rassure
dans le film c'est vraiment la
chorégraphie tête au cordeau vrai bon
alors je ne sais pas plus que vous avez
tourné combien de fois cette scène toute
la journée la journée vous avez été oui
alors est en tout cas vous benjamin
castaldi de le suspense r on est reparti
pour faire 3 2 à 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr benjamin castaldi les chiens et
les chats lee le shérif